we are witness to monumental human
progress
over the past few decades the expansion
of the global marketplace
has lifted a third of the world's
population out of extreme poverty
yet we are also witness to an astounding
failure
our efforts to lift people up have left
behind those in the harshest forms of
poverty
the ultra poor what it means to be ultra
poor
goes beyond the monetary definition that
we're all familiar with
living on less than two dollars a day it
goes even beyond
not having assets like livestock or land
to be ultra poor means to be stripped of
your dignity
purpose and self-worth it means living
in isolation
because you're a burden to your own
community it means
being unable to imagine a better future
for yourself and your family
by the end of 2019 about 400 million
people
were living in ultra poverty worldwide
that's more than the populations of the
united states and canada
combined and when calamity strikes
whether it's a pandemic a natural
disaster or a man-made crisis
these numbers spike astronomically
higher
my father fazle abed gave up a corporate
career
to establish brac here in bangladesh in
1972.
bangladesh was a wreck having just gone
through a devastating cyclone
followed by a brutal war for
independence
working with the poorest of the poor my
father realized
that poverty was more than the lack of
income
and assets it was also a lack of hope
people were trapped in poverty because
they felt their condition
was immutable poverty to them was like
the sun
and the moon something given to them by
god
for poverty reduction programs to
succeed they would need to instill hope
and self-worth so that with a little sub
support
people could lift themselves out of
poverty brac went on to pioneer
the graduation approach a solution to
ultra poverty
that addresses both income poverty and
the poverty of hope
the approach works primarily with women
because women
are the most affected by ultra poverty
but also the ones most likely to pull
themselves and their
families out of it over a two-year
period
we essentially do four things one
we meet a woman's basic needs by giving
her
food or cash ensuring the minimum to
survive
two we move her towards a decent
livelihood
by giving her an asset like livestock
and training her
to earn money from it three we train her
to save
budget and invest her new wealth and
four
we help to integrate her socially first
into groups of women like her
and then into her community each of
these elements
is key to the success of the others but
the real magic
is the hope and sense of possibility
that women develop
through the close mentorship they
receive
let me tell you about jorina jorina was
born
in a remote village in northern
bangladesh
she never went to school and at the age
of 15
she was married off to an abusive
husband he eventually abandoned her
leaving her with no income and two
children
who were not in school and were severely
malnourished
with no one to turn to for help she had
no hope
jorina joined brac's graduation program
in 2005.
she received a dollar a week two cows
enterprise training
and a weekly visit from a mentor she
began to build her assets
but most importantly she began to
imagine
a better future for herself and her
children
if you were to visit jorina's village
today you would find that she runs the
largest general store in her area she
will proudly show you the land she
bought
and the house she built since we began
this program
in 2002 2 million bangladeshi women
have lifted themselves and their
families out of ultra poverty
that's almost nine million people the
program
which costs five hundred dollars per
household runs for only two years
but the impact goes well beyond that
researchers at the london school of
economics
found that even seven years after
entering the program
92 percent of participants had
maintained or increased
their income assets and consumption
esther duflo and abhijit banerjee
the mit economists who won the nobel
prize last year
led multi-country evaluations that
identified graduation as one of the most
effective ways
to break the poverty trap but my father
wasn't content
to have found a solution that worked for
some people
he always wanted to know whether we were
being ambitious enough
in terms of scale so when we achieved
nationwide scale in bangladesh
he wanted to know how we could scale it
globally
and that has to involve governments
governments already dedicate
billions of dollars on poverty reduction
programs
but so much of that money is wasted
because these programs
either don't reach the poorest and even
the ones that do
fail to have significant long-term
impact
we are working to engage governments to
help them to adopt and scale graduation
programs
themselves maximizing the impact
of the billions of dollars they already
allocate
to fight ultra poverty our plan
is to help another 21 million people
lift themselves out of ultra poverty
in eight countries over the next six
years
with black teams on-site and embedded in
each country
in july of 2019 my father was diagnosed
with terminal brain cancer
and given four months to live as he
transitioned out of brac
after leading the organization for 47
years
he reminded us that throughout his life
he saw optimism triumph over despair
that when you light the spark of
self-belief in people
even the poorest can transform their
lives
my father passed away in december
he lit that spark for millions of people
and in the final days of his life he
implored us
to continue to do so for millions more
this opportunity is ours for the taking
so let's stop
imagining a world without ultra poverty
and start
building that world together thank you